I want to be a writer but my family is
stuck in another century writing isn't a
job I need you to do more makeup ich
bitte kiss the girl
and get out of this dump
Bruce the direct line tall destroying
this shitty world seriously what does he
know about our worlds
[Music]
you should be listening to our music
before you start getting confused and
hating yourself
I feel like this film yes it's a love
letter to Bruce's music but I feel like
it's also a love letter to lyrics and
lyrics in music and how lyrics in the
words of a song can sort of change your
life and so let's start out there and
just sort of what that experience was
kind of bringing this film out at
Sundance and and and how that experience
maybe changed your life you know vivec
stop you know what people are gonna like
like you can hope that people would like
something you can guess you can hope for
it but you don't know like there's never
a certain like I I didn't know that
there'd be a round of applause after the
film like you know we could have well we
could well have you know had the film
and there just been silence like I mean
it's anything was possible at that
moment so when it did finish and start
hearing and then it turned into like and
then people started standing up I was
like five minutes standing ovations
Hammad like no one no one wanted to stop
it just felt so odd because you like
it's it's surreal because we just did
this thing in England and then Grenda
was like oh we're going to Sundance
alright then cool ice random but alright
and then all of a sudden we're here and
they're lovely deal with noon on Warner
Brothers and they're back in US which is
amazing validation because you know when
I grew up that's the that's the logo you
see on the Harry Potter films yeah I
guess so weird my childhood films and
it's like a psychological sort of
validation for me that I never thought
would be possible I was saying to
sufferers in the car on the way back we
were driving back to the airport at Salt
Lake and I'm sitting there and I was
like how does this happen that you are
47 year old Pakistani man we've got
about a 60 year old Punjabi woman and
this 20 year old brown thing yeah all of
a sudden
like people are liking us and people are
liking what we've done and people liking
the work that we've made over in someone
that's so far away it was mental it was
really cool you know now what this is
such a exceptional film I feel like and
you know to speak to what you were
saying there I feel like we've never
seen a film like this you know and if
you're gonna kind of use a film that has
Bruce Springsteen's music into woven
through it you know you almost expect it
to be about a blue-collar kid from
Jersey or something like that and so
it's such a remarkable story what was
sort of your the biggest thing that you
learned from that that helped you kind
of learn who your character was and had
a player well as soon as I read the
script I identified Ruth Eliza
immediately she was exactly the same as
me when I was like 17 16 angry political
like furiously energetic and hopeful at
the same time so I was very drawn to her
immediately but the the general sort of
uplifting inclusive nature of the film
and how you know it's not really about
Bruce Springsteen or even about a boy in
luton it's sort of a universal message
really isn't it about how music can help
you overcome any problems you're having
in life it's about growing up it's about
falling in love for the first time and
you know for me but yeah so those those
themes are really Universal and other
than the fact that I was drawn to the
character because she was basically me
they they drew me to the to the script
immediately and Erin what about what
about you what was sort of the biggest
thing that helped the biggest note that
you got that helped you sort of figure
out who this character was and the time
and the setting the fact that I
he's a turban wearing Punjabi guy and I
come from the similar background so my I
didn't have to fetch too far for
research I'd obviously met him but this
is 20 30 years on so he's a completely
different person now so a lot of the
research that I needed to do I obviously
asked him questions but then I went back
to my own family who have grown up in
though
and bein sakes in a predominantly white
area so I didn't have to look too far
for that did you listen
was there a particular song that you
listened to from Bruce that sort of
helped you kind of figure out the the
state of your characters yeah it was
sort of intimidating to be able to have
to think you know after sit down and
listen to this stuff
this is the songs you know within the
film as well as you know the rest of it
so I can get a glimpse of it so I did
and I started listening and I thought
I'm not gonna like this and I kept this
thing I was like and I kept on listening
and then quite like it was in the film
it sort of hit me and I had a weird
incredibly cheesy epiphany moment
incredibly cliches that sounds and it
was just odd because you know I was
listening to very different music at the
time music where music personally we're
you know the lyrics weren't important
and you know I like to go tune I was
like cool great and I started listening
to these words and I'm sitting there
like what's going on and then I thought
you know what I've got maybe I've got a
good back to me a bit so I went I went
and listened to some like chart music
like premature midlife crisis where I
was there like what what's going on I
have I not known about this and why do I
like this because it's absurd like why
would I why would I like something like
that there's no reason that I should
like that music but it's the words and
his words are amazing he's a poet
this guy is incredible you've never
heard lyrics like is that Billy Joel
Billy Joel you try and raise your kids
right Josh he doesn't have lyrics he has
ammunition
whatever whatever song whatever mood
you're in there's a song for all of it
and there's a way is his music is in a
way a coping mechanism yeah and it
really works so it really is so yeah and
I found the same I found the exact same
thing once you get become a fan you're
there you're there good to see you visit
I'm going to st. Bruce Springsteen's
hometown I can't think of a better
reason to visit the United States and to
see the home of the boss you know at
what point in your life did you realize
that your relationship with Bruce
Springsteen and his music is worth
writing a memoir about well I mean I was
a fan since I was 16 but that was just
you know my dad used to just say to me
why are you giving all your money to
Bruce and you're traveling around the
world spending money that you don't have
to see him and then I became a
journalist and then a publishing company
came up to me and said you know we like
your work as a journalist would you
think about writing a book I never
really thought about writing a book I
thought well how am I gonna you know
we're gonna have 300 pages of something
to write about so I thought what my
obsessions I thought well myself and
Bruce Springsteen so I thought I think
that I could probably spend the next
year writing about so is at that point
that I started writing the book and as I
was writing the book there was a bit of
me that was thinking inside this there
is a film there is something in this and
I thought the only person who could
possibly do it would be kirinda and
we're lucky we knew each other because
we were friends and she's a Springsteen
fan as well and so I sent it to her
towards the end of that and I said you
know what do you think and and that's
that's the beginning of the journey of
the film and what did you think it was
great obviously being a Springsteen fan
yeah and I said to suffer as I think
there's definitely a movie here what was
interesting for me though was but he
like many first-time writers he was
really trying to protect his family
while at the same time tell their story
and so there was you know that was
interesting to me because I do the same
you know in my work and so I knew that
the journey that we had to go on and I
had to take a phrase on was to go deeper
and forget about himself and his own
family and start thinking about
a story and this character becoming
someone else and I think that gave him
the freedom meant to think about the
possibilities and who the parents might
be so it's kind of inspired by safra's
his book in his life and then we then
went forward to turn it into a great
movie that initially a script that we
were really hoping that bruce
springsteen would like well I mean
that's the crux of this right so you're
gonna make this movie you have to make
it with Bruce's blessing and so tell me
how that happened so I said to him this
is great it's a great book but it's only
gonna happen with Bruce we have to get
to Bruce and the promise was coming out
and I've been invited to the premiere of
the promise in London so I thought the
documentary of the making of darkness on
the edge of town yeah and so let's go so
we'd both Wed like a little fan fan kids
and we both stood on either side of the
red carpet and we were some waiting for
Brewster Kahle but we both had cameras
so he could film each other with Bruce
walking past us
we were waiting and waiting in there
were tears and he was walking through
and then the most amazing thing happened
Bruce turned round and saw sufferance
now looking at Sarah and seizing he's a
very distinctive looking and if you're
Bruce Springsteen at the concert and
this kid keeps popping up at these
concerts
you're gonna notice him so Bruce
couldn't recognize him and walked over
to him and said I read your book it's a
beautiful thing and at that point I you
know when you write a book like this you
obviously hope that he you extend it to
him Mike Hudson - I had no idea that
he'd even seen it so I completely just
lost it I ran over while he was losing
it and went straight to business and
said Bruce it's so great you've read the
book you loved it we will on turn it
into a movie I did Brenda like back home
you know so that I started being really
uncool as well and then he was standing
there looking at the two of us and I
said we really need your support to make
this movie and he sort of went sounds
good
talk to John
then John Lando was behind him and Bruce
walked on and John went what are you
guys talking about let's look what's
going on and then that was it that was
the beginning we were in touch with
Bruce and his managers but the thing
also was like you know it meant that
when you're writing something like this
you're working like this it doesn't
really matter if people finances or
ultimately Bruce doesn't like it this
thinking that has everything and so
that's like and that's a big thing
that's an exam you cannot afford to fail
yeah yeah yeah it's one guy yeah so we
had to really work hard to tell a story
that you know was worthy of Bruce and
one of the things I kept saying safra's
and criticals he has an encyclopedic
knowledge of Bruce and every single
thing he's ever recorded we had to make
songs our own you know and worked hard
on making every song feel like Bruce had
written it for us in the screenplay and
took ownership of it really and so by
the time we finished and we said the
script to Bruce I think Bruce was so
like blown away by this story of this
kid who sort of made sense of his own
life with all his words
Bruce's words I think he just was
charmed by it and we were waiting for a
reply and two weeks went by sufferers
emailed me a million times during that
period and we heard anything anything
and then finally we got a reply and the
word came back to us that Bruce said I'm
all good with this and that was a green
light and I think that you know with
Springsteen he doesn't you know he's got
that position now he can choose what he
wants to do with these things and I
think I my suspicion is that the reason
he liked it is because it was not a film
about how great he is
it's about how the power of his words
and what they can do and I think you've
been an artist of any form you know you
want to try and create work that touches
people and makes a difference and you
know I think he must have probably might
have found it slightly flattering that
our kid from a what looked like a very
different world to his had a very
tangible connection to
his music and I think that that's you
know because it wasn't a had geography
about him and it wasn't a biopic it was
showing this is what your words did to
this character and I think maybe that's
what he but also the film it's not just
about Joffrey it's about his family and
I think that's interesting because it's
a window into a family like that that
you might not know you know but you
realize that is as universal as yourself
and I think Bruce also really liked that
cultural take and also you know there is
other music it's not just Bruce's music
and in particular there's Asian music
the dad listens to old and you know
music by Mohammed Rafi you know who it
was a big kind of it didn't in the film
star playback singer and then also the
sister listens to Bhangra music goes to
what we had then were Bhangra daytimers
and so the music is very the film it has
a very rich soundtrack and so Bruce's
music is contextualized within the world
of what it meant to be British Asian in
1987 you know for that family and I
think that's what makes it different to
it just being a you know because people
might think oh it's just about this kid
and Bruce it is it yes about a lot more
than that and also the central
relationship one of the central
relationships as you know is about a kid
and a dad working-class family I mean
that's rep you there I'm sure that I saw
that different from working-class
families in Jersey and I think hopefully
what the film shows is you know the
things we have in common
underneath the things that look like
they're different
you